all right 6 27 on your wednesday morning
big squeeze 95 515 between the spaghetti
mill and eastern oh it's about to get
realer
thousands of you have gotten into all
too well the brake light parade of the
big squeeze during both the morning and
afternoon commute but bracelet brace
herself for more than just the
restriction of two lanes in each
direction they're going to be ramp
closures some overnight one lane only
restrictions next week but the big deal
starts sunday night with the complete
closure of eastern under the freeway now
ndot contractors had originally planned
to reopen eastern the night of the 10th
but that closure has been extended to
the 13th so that bridge over eastern
it's going to be replaced in phases this
closure is so that the southbound 95
bridge can be demolished that's what the
two lanes of traffic have been all about
reshaping the center of the freeway so
the north and southbound lanes can be
shifted back and forth to accommodate
whatever work may be going on yeah we
mentioned the closure of eastern a
couple of days ago and as important as i
want to think our stories are we could
mention the closure all day every day
until sunday and still come sunday night
some folks are going to say nobody told
me
we want you to check out the ndot
website i515project.com
all the information you need now we have
that link along with all of our driving
you crazy stories on our website
eightnewsnow.com you click traffic than
driving you crazy buckle up drive
carefully and please put down the phone
if there is something driving you crazy
the email address traffic 8 8newsnow.com